hello everyone welcome back to collider
for another interview and specifically
for another cobra kai
interview and i just i don't need to say
this anymore but i can't get enough of
this show
and i can't get enough of this cast
because they are all an absolute delight
including
the one and only martin cove how are you
doing
i'm good very good before we do anything
we have to say that john crease is not a
villain he's just misunderstood
i think i have a question on this list
that's going to let you extrapolate on
that even more
i did want to start by going all the way
back to karate kid though and
you know just focusing on what it took
to actually make those movies and the
specific question i had for you about
that is
i know that the very beginning of the
second film was originally meant to be
the ending of the first film so i was
curious what your reaction to hearing
that change was because you know
both versions do kind of end with defeat
for crease
but one could have been a much more
extreme level of defeat after just one
movie
well we were waiting outside for about
three hours
and i practiced with pat johnson who was
a stunt coordinator who
used to run with chuck norris and and
sort of you know he was his partner in
the tournament scene in the 60s and 70s
so he was very you know a very astute as
a teacher and we worked separately
and it was my fight scene i didn't have
any fight scenes i just had a lot of
attitude
throughout the whole movie and so we
practiced this fight scene which
ultimately aired as the beginning of
cortica
ii and we were all waiting to do it and
we were waiting three hours out in the
parking lot 1983
and then all of a sudden word came down
that john avilson and jerry weintraub
decided
it was best to end the movie in the
tournament with the free
freeze frame of miyagi and
i said okay you know and i was a little
depressed because i really wanted to
work out i really wanted to do the fight
scene
and it turned out to be it was the right
decision because it was such a
feel-good ending you know i've seen the
movie in reverse
i have seen the movie with ralph at an
autograph show
from behind the screen while they're
screening it to 2000 people
and it was we watched the last 20
minutes
in reverse behind a screen
and it was brilliant we still got chills
it was still a great ending
you know so it affected me
but i was glad to be back on the team
and then
you know carnegie three was a different
story karate kid three
was all about me and my vehicle and then
i had a
tv series called hard time on planet
earth and i couldn't do it
because i was not available at the same
time and they brought in a character
called
terry silver to put me on vacation to do
what i was originally scripted to do
and create the sting between ralph and
sean kane
i'm so tempted to jump into my season
three questions now but i'm gonna hold
back and and maybe put a pin
in terry silver for a second back to
that fight scene though and actually
before you even get into the fight scene
i did want to know what it was
like filming just the argument portion
of that scene with billy because
that's really the first time johnny
stands up to chris so
for you just as an actor are you kind of
seeing
a whole nother layer to billy's range
get added
to his performance in that moment but
you know john crease
his students can't lose so you know i i
watched
the entire movie for body language one
one day in
in atlanta and
i really wanted to see body language i
wanted to invest in this character
that everybody celebrated because i was
doing cagney lacy and to me initially
he was just another heavy and i was on a
break from cagney and lacy and
you know we didn't even know what to
expect no one expected this hit
karate kid was just the wrong title we
kept thought of it as a bruce lee movie
but the bottom line was i invested my
time in watching body language watching
just attitude i even turned the sound
out
and it was really interesting because he
never
was excited about his students he never
was
you know happy that they won or he and
most of the time he was indifferent
and it all turned back to the fact that
not everything was the way it was
supposed to be
you know no mercy means what he learned
and later on
which you'll learn in future episodes
but no mercy comes from a very specific
place and honestly
um billy didn't have
a chance at that point and neither did
any of them because
he talks to them and he says step back
you know he's at the height
of his emotionality there because he
lost
and because he lost to a a man who he
loathes
who is teaching the opposite of cobra
kai
miyagido you know be sweet and
you know it's the right way to teach
karate because
miyagi taught what was it he taught it
as a defensive art
while john crees taught karate as a
offensive sport
and that was the difference and you know
spiritually they were just at odds all
the time
so i don't think billy or the rest of
the cobra kai could have stood up to
greece at that point
it was the height of intensity of a man
losing who hasn't lost
probably since he was in vietnam
and then moving into the fight portion
of that and specifically
you know when he finally has his fists
go through the window and gets blood on
his hands
i'll never forget the look on your face
and now that i've seen
you know future movies and cobra kai i
have a feeling i know where that fear
on his face comes from but in that
moment while you're shooting it what's
kind of
going through your head as crease very
interesting story
we rehearsed that several times and the
window never broke
the special effects man could never get
the charge in the base of the window
for the window to shatter and i was
supposed to be about this far
from the window and it shatters and it
never did
so he promised me it would work on this
tank
rehearsal rehearsal rehearsal still
couldn't i'd smack up against it i was a
it was a lunge punch so a lot of force
behind it
and just never the
window never broke they promised me it
would break so i
backed up and i said i'll just punch
this instead of lunging and punching
sure enough it didn't break i broke it
right through shards of glass you know
shards sticking out of my
going in was real and what you saw
coming out was you know that look on the
face was com
that was the next day we shot that and
coming out we shot the next day
and all the the accumulation
of him losing and me almost losing
my entire hand it was an accumulation of
emotions
that contributed to the fear because i
don't think you ever see john crease
fearful and you don't seem fearful in
the series either
and there's a level of emotional
misunderstanding there
that he's had a loss of himself it's
like you know
when someone knows they've made a
mistake or someone knows
they're entertaining uncharted ground
emotionally
strange things happen and it could have
been a little cartoonish
i think but john wanted it big
that fear to be big appleson you know
and
and i think i would have played a little
more neutral but
bottom line was you listened to him
because he
didn't give a lot of direction because
he also as a director believes
that if i'm giving you the job and he
used to verbalize this if i'm giving you
the job
you know what you're doing i don't have
to tell you you know
so being all that said that's what came
out of that
you know honking in my nose
i also did wonder if the fear on his
face may be kind of tapped into his
experience fighting fighting in the army
too and maybe just
i don't know the trauma that could
follow you from something like that
yeah i mean the last time john crease
was afraid
was back there so um
you know anything is possible it's like
having a relationship you know you have
a relationship with a woman
and and then something comes up
for you from 10 years ago some affair
you had and you didn't know she knew
about it
and then all of a sudden you've had a
great relationship for 10 years and
something dark comes up
you don't really know how to react
because you're
you're lost it was not something you
anticipated
in the communication of this
relationship so
it's kind of the unknown it's really
john creese is
not comfortable with anything other than
being triumphant you know and as
students we don't lose
in kobukai you know it's just not an
option you know
mercy is for the weak here on the street
somebody confronts you
he's the enemy an enemy deserves no
mercy and that's it
you know um but robert came in
to really give you a little capsule
version without robert cayman
and without these writers of the show
this success doesn't exist cayman
truly wrote wax on works off no mercy
sweep the leg we're still saying these
lines 35 years later
and you know what are we saying the
force be with you we can compare it to
play it against sam
we can compare it to you know frankly
scarlet i don't give a damn you know
from gone with the wind
but that's how good the writing is we're
still saying these lines
35 years later and it's not going to
stop now
i hope not you know i hope i i hope i
i am a big proponent of the western and
i really hope that
somewhere along the line we can get a
western which i think
is the heritage of american cinema
and i think that one day i'd love to be
able to have
a success like cobra kai but in that
genre
and it's going to take a lot of playing
because from 1967 to 19
from 1920 to 1967 one of every movie
that came out of
hollywood was a western so it's it's
tricky it's really tricky but we'll see
we're gonna get i believe it
i have a a very specific uh karate
related question
for you so in karate kid and also
in cobra kai we hear different
variations
of the kia often like there there's a
lot of ites and also at the very very
end of season two of cobra kai there's a
very intense i think it's high q
and i do wonder did the writers talk to
you about
which which version they want to use at
which point and for what purpose
you take a lot from the stunt
coordinators who are brilliant the stunt
quarters are brilliant
but i use the key eye from pat johnson
the heights that was his kiai his deal
was putting your hands in the belt
his deal was occasionally like this you
know
and his body language was very important
and his attitude is very important
sweetest man in the world pat johnson
but a complete killer
i mean did just brilliant he was so
brilliant with karate
and um the key i
i always insist on using ike's but other
people
just do a key ti with a breath and
whatever comes out
comes out you know everybody's different
but in the dojo
i use it and when i'm teaching the class
they pretty much say heights but it's in
their own style so it's just an exhale
of course number one to frighten your
opponent but number two to get as much
strength as you can
on your forward thrust or your kick or
whatever you're doing
in forward motion you know absolutely it
definitely makes
makes a big impression that's another
thing that i find people repeating
very often now so jumping into some
specific
season two scenes here i wonder what
it's like
just for for you like not even kris but
you martin cove
doing the scenes with johnny where
you know chris and johnny are either
working together or even
the scene in a in the shelter where
crease is opening up to him
we know the path that crease is on but
is there any part of you that kind of
still aches for him to become
a better person and to continue this
journey with johnny
i ask the writers all the time to write
him with a vulnerability
and that scene in the shelter i mean
i cried supermarket openings you know so
i really like those moments a lot and
they like the dark side you know
um i like to mix it up but that scene in
the shelter the scene where i give him
his trophy
at the end and you know i think hayden i
think
hayden who wrote this narration at the
end of episode 1
episode 10 when i'm leaving and billy
calls me back and says hold on
and the narration on the page said john
crease smiles
is it a smile of being
happy and comfortable to be back at
johnny's side
or is it the smile of a master
manipulator
you know that's the stage direction on
the bottom of the page and then when the
script was over
so i think we i did it ten times with
everything i could
imagine somewhere but some of it was
that vulnerable guy who's really happy
to be there
some of it was a manipulation but i
think that
john crease loves johnny lawrence so
much
it's his son the only thing that he can
content to more than his son
is for as much affection he's capable of
conjuring up is cobra khan cobra kai you
violate kobrakai
there's nothing left there's no
relationship he loves billy so much
but yet billy violated cobra kai you
know
and um it's kobrakai's primary
so that's you know the vulnerability
comes from i believe
really being able to focus in on what he
loves
and having a heartbreak that he has to
do what he has to do
because he believes that johnny will
thank him one day
for setting him straight that cobra kai
is the way to go
not anything any more lenient
so given the fact that he looks at
johnny like a son
at this point johnny's pushed him away
quite a few times
do you think kris is in a position now
where he's looking at johnny as an enemy
or
is that father-son vibe still there and
could he try to pull him back in
i think the father-son vibe you know
doesn't change i mean how many stories
have we
heard of of criminals that do terrible
things but their parents are still in
the courtroom
the parents are still there to support
even though the child is
somewhat lost and he's criminal i think
johnny will always be my second love
you know and there's a lot of support
for a second love
you know integrity and and compliance
with karate
is number one the integrity of
cobra kai and then comes
i have to help johnny as often as i can
even though he rejects me
he just doesn't know from john crease's
point of view
he doesn't know what's the best form you
know
and that'll last i think if the show
went five or six seasons
i don't think that would ever change for
my character you know
like will you ever change for the love
of your son or your
child and or your baby it just
you know life will change circumstances
will change
but in here pretty much you have to be
violated
big time for that to change so do you
think crease
is redeemable at a point absolutely
okay but it depends you got to remember
that it depends on what you know
what really from his point of view why
should he be redeemed
he is in the right he's going down the
highway in the in the right
wagon he's traveling down on the best
horse
in the race you know and
he doesn't feel it's even necessary but
to answer your question if things became
intolerable
i think the character is very redeemable
because
i enjoy playing those moments of
redemption
you're good at it too you know thank you
so
you said it's cobra kai then it's johnny
i wonder if there's room increase his
life for a third love in that tier and
if maybe hawk might fill that position
in
season three it's a possibility
the writers i mean i love paul caucus
hawk is johnny lawrence you know 20
20 30 years ago and i like his passion
you know um i would love to see the
third entity
because it would be total surprise the
third entity
a woman what kind of woman
would tolerate a man like john crease
and that character alone
would be fascinating to have in a story
that we keep bringing in
all kinds of elements that nobody
expects you know
you're suggesting things and it's making
my head swirl with ideas because now i'm
pushing hawk out and i'm moving tori
into that position and that can be a
nice challenge for
maybe eli to re-emerge
sir well oh god you have a very good
imagination god
you know that that's going out there
that's out there i
i had a you know torah is terrific
and it's really great to play as an
actor
opening up things that you yourself
highly identify with it's not a stretch
because i'm not
john creese you know but john crees
comes into my life
much more often than you think on a
daily basis it just
comes up because he's a celebrated
character that some
somehow in the back of your mind don't
shut them off
you know daniel day-lewis keeps his
character for six months
you know um they just are
when they're well written they are
highly identifiable
within your personal life it is true i
mean as
as a kid growing up doing karate i
guarantee you if cobra kai existed when
i was doing that
i definitely would have gravitated
towards a character
like tori i mean like she's a kick-ass
strong
leading lady and i would have been
totally rooting for her non-stop
yeah yeah there's that level of you know
i've always felt being a part of cagney
and lacy for six years
and they would always get these great
cases and i would get missing persons in
public latrines
you know that's what i would victorize
becky always felt as well as martin cove
that a woman could do anything a man
could do i've always felt that way
and yet the character of course never
did the character was a chauvinist
but i was you know doing a tv series for
six years
always feeling that way because it was
so well written
what they did and what they covered as
police women
and the show was ahead of its time
because no one was ready for
two female police women in 1984
but you know it's there's no
there's no line in in the sand if
there's no you know you're on this side
that side
it's all merged now it's not like the
alamo where there's a line
i'm going to stay and you're going to go
you know
it's it's all pretty much shared in
society all of us
you know we all have the same purposes
to be happy and comfortable
and as an artist to be real with your
moment that's all
absolutely for the better there so i
know you probably can't tell me too much
about season three but
i did want to know maybe about the
evolution of crease's fighting style and
the pillars of his technique are we kind
of are we gonna
see everything that we knew about cobra
kai kind of get
taken to another level after you know
again
johnny turns his back on him a second
time around
well you're going to see a lot of
leadership you're going to see and you
will see
unquestionably there'll be a lot of i
can't expound on how much action
but there's a terrific you know amount
of that
and you'll see the prowess
you know i can't really say very much
but
it's quite exciting the
and it's very surprising all the
elements very surprising
and you'll you'll be very happy because
it goes
further into the story of the characters
you love
and these characters whether they're
myself who's reasonably disreputable
and misunderstood or it's johnny
lawrence who's the
misfit or it's ralph who's the
stationary
decent soul of all of us in essence um
you'll see the characters do surprising
things that are just
you know wonderful to hold on to just
like season one and two
we hold on to these characters because
they created so well
and our writers you know hayden
schlossberg and josh shield and
and um john horowitz they really
they really know what they're doing and
they are big fans of the show
it's not like working for someone on
another agenda who's been in the
business 40 years and
sits around smokes a cigar and you know
just got his favorites
they really developed these characters
from the past from the movies
they went in there and took cuts
in what you saw season one and two they
took unused
angles from the archives of
things that were not used in the movie
certain cuts that
john evelson didn't use and they would
go in and
select them and use them in different
flashbacks that you saw in the show
and it's brilliant just wonderful that's
how much they care
oh it's true you can feel it while
you're watching it too
so i'm going to go back to something you
already brought up i have a feeling you
might not be able to answer this but i'm
going to go for it
how at the very end crease has cobra kai
how exactly is he paying for it and
could that maybe bring back a certain
source of financing into the equation
well um i know what you're hinting to
and uh
but we can't even go there
but i mean i know exactly where you're
going but the thing is that john crease
because i brought that question up can
you afford all this
the bottom line is he's making money
from the students there he's very
popular
at the end you know now the students
based on that fight
you know in school that now they want to
be on
as everybody does wants to be on the
side the winners
and um cobra kai
will increase in the amount of students
will increase the amount of revenue
and being a badass because cobra and
billy says it too he says
you know cobra kai is badass it really
is
and it doesn't mean you have to go as
far as john crease goes
from billy's standpoint today in season
two
but john doesn't feel that way you know
since increase doesn't feel that way he
doesn't feel this
there's a margin of evil he doesn't feel
that way it's
it's a it's a um
it's an instructional procedure
to succeed in cobra kai and you will get
it
if you join you come in on time you
profess no mercy you profess mercy is
for the weak
and your fear does not exist in the dojo
for you know
defeat does not exist in dojo as long as
you stay on that
he'll always have students he'll always
have an income
he'll always keep kobukai open and if he
doesn't
he'll do what he you know what he did
with the landlord before
you know and he is a conspirator
but he really feels it's different if
you're conspiracy with a negative
approach or you're a conspirator to make
the world a little better
john crease thinks he by his conspiracy
him putting
his puzzle together in his own way
he's making the world a better place
i'll take that tease
a potentially huge spoiler question and
you turned it into something that was
just a good tease to make me even more
excited for what's to come
it's a good question because i know
where you're going but it's like you
know
you can't because it's and to be
perfectly honest i don't even know the
answer to that question totally
so we'll keep it you know the
undercurrent of the of the interview you
know
i really don't even know the answer it
almost makes me happy or you don't know
the answer because i feel like
that's a good sign that there's like so
much more room to explore
as the show goes on and on because a lot
i've been looking at the comments and
interviews that we've been doing and one
of the big ones is that i'm so glad
season three has come into netflix but
make sure like you do more and more like
people are we haven't even seen season
three yet and people are already
freaking out that that's
like it's not going to go on after that
like it's going to be the biggest thing
ever
netflix it's really just terrific
organization
i mean they just i've been doing
publicity for them you know
and they just have a really good feeling
about this because they're so inspired
they're inspired you know and um
it's great to work with someone like
that it's just wonderful
most of the time you do a television
show and i've done force
five series the network gets behind the
show
and that's it you have to hire a
publicist to help your career go along
with
paralleling netflix really
oversees even reactors
to make sure that we're doing the right
shows or we're coming on your show
we've got the right things to say you
know it and it's it's great to see that
and you know it's kind of interesting
you know it's the right time
covert 19 has been so limiting i lost
three movies
that got postponed that one was a
western
but you know there's a silver lining to
some of this
it's still relating i spend more time
with the family i can cultivate
my relationship more and um
it just you can plan more and look at
the world and you're a little slower
because you're home
you're not preoccupied with our lives
per se
and as an actor you really can focus in
on what you and i are doing the
different alternatives
of what makes a character more
successful or less
you know yeah that i mean i'm always
grasping for silver linings
right now and a big one has definitely
been being able to revisit
cobra kai on netflix i mean i'm not just
saying it because i'm talking to you
truly that has just like brightened my
days the last couple of days being able
to watch it over and over and now being
able to take it and share it with you
know my little cousins and my family who
have yet to see it so
i am very happy to see the cobra kai
community grow and i'm rooting for you
guys in season three
martin thank you so much for hanging out
with us today uh
you're very gracious thank you it was a
lot of fun next time we'll talk about
a western that i've got development then
we can talk about the wild bunch good
the bad and the ugly all that stuff yes
please you know it'll be fun combined
with cobra kai you know
i wouldn't mind taking that we don't
talk about that stuff nearly enough
yeah it's the heritage of our whole
world of cinema
you know and we should talk about it
more often anyway take care of yourself